hi herzlich willkommen zu meinem
heutigen videoleuchte ich sitz hier
zusammen heute probieren wir drei nichts
zu lachen und zwar während wir uns den
galileo adventskalender anschauen
richtig hinein fahren war galileo
größeren man ihr dann habe ich noch
damals als ich ein projekt schon video
auf so ein video zu billig gemacht habe
und er noch nicht zehnmal soviel hughes
hatte wie ich youtube kalender wer
nachrichten klebestreifen in sein
gesicht und und seit 16 jahren also viel
mehr wenn man richtig lernt aber
manchmal gibt es dinge die man nicht
blenden irgendwas läuft jahre und dann
kostenlos sind 11 sollte einst eher und
rassistisch
was war das denn gerade wenn die
lachende ich hab nicht gedacht
noch mal wieder na ja doch ich habe auch
gehört hey aber doch nicht darüber wie
das ganze generell nicht lassen
aus diesem video einfach keinen spaß
haben bleibt unbedingt dran weil am ende
des videos werden die klebestreifen
abgibt
wann bin erst geben wenn er leute
vergessen sie auch gerne knusprige
hoffen frischen und warten
[Musik]
alle drei sehen sie was nicht läuft kann
ich umgehen kann ich umgehen ist so
leute weiter
[Musik]
ich hab das display
hallo ich bin der chef von martin kares
was sie können was noch nicht nur 7
statt
[Gelächter]
er spürte hier wären das 48 lebt ohne
zucker schmeckt einfach und so lang so
lang widerstand
[Musik]
doch schmeckt so lange wie meine
tabletten abhängig wie lange das
schmeckt ich muss sagen ich habe zwar
bin ich gelacht am meisten gehörte ich
will hier nicht ohne zucker extra lall
im geschmack hier posiert oder sowie zu
lachen dadurch 1000 und 1 1 1
wo kann ich noch vogel erzählt ich habe
dieses scheint ja mit melitta top papier
wäre das nicht passiert
damit gelingt es immer und alle bleibt
heil sieht keinen fetten kein anpacken
kein fettes schwein kein land und kein
schmutziges backblech mellitzer toppits
backpapier
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
vorne empfang
der opel vectra technik die geister
begeistert nicht die geister begeistert
nicht was er da ist 1&1 wenn die bachs
am sonntagmorgen zu sprechen sind dann
sind sie wahrscheinlichkeit und zu
sprechen
dann legten sie nicht woher wissen sie
das
ich weiß es eben auch ihr müsst ihr ja
in den daten gerechnet
auflage müssen wir halt mich marius und
königen vögel im garten zu gehört ich
weiß mein geburtstag gefreut und mit
baden sagt in seinen klauen muss
brötchen gebissen
dann plötzlich das lizenzfreie sagt
glaubst du ja mal
sie haben bestimmt megaauftrag probleme
die youtube kacke katalog nicht
eingesetzt beiseite und seien harte
riesen wird spannt krachte auf den
frühstückstisch verletzt
live machen uns mitmachen weil ja alles
dafür das angemessen
ich glaube ja kopf schüttelte
auch stehen beinahe wäre der könig auf
sand ausgerutscht
kein penalty
chris nicht was geschehen war ich habe
mir jetzt vorstelle ich habe mir den
kalender so mies aufgespart wichtiger
heute sonst mit jetzt mit den safe jeden
tag gegeben weil kein leben größer ist
deine augen
am brünig wird auf einem esel und musste
aufpassen dass wir die vollständig aus
der hand rutschte warum hast du dich
aufgepasst warstein
[Gelächter]
er löst sich alles nicht aber du willst
dass die geht
ihre neuen leiter für
kundenzufriedenheit hilde clemens ihre
neue diese klemme
die würden dann aber trocken ganz
ehrlich davon dass wir den haushalt
einer die aufwändig ist es ja derzeit
einen monat vorher können wir aber
trotzdem also der der muss richtig krass
durchgeführt haben ja was vor produziert
wurde er schaut deshalb auf jeden fall
vorbei auch wenn wir nochmal drauf
recken ich habe mir überlegt dass
vielleicht sporadisch im dezember mal
mache mir immer mal wieder was anschauen
von ihm schaut auf jeden fall aber mir
einfach einmal war dabei und auch das
original an erklimmen
das ist mein wunsch also die beschaffung
ist doch nur ein paar krümel
dass bei diesen aus dem duell einen
popel junge ist noch ein weiter weg wie
mache ich mir mal die andere ab nicht
selbst wird ja dass man heute sagen der
tagen erfahren hatte
ok oh du warst du kannst du dir einfach
so einfach so einmal zwischen der regel
nicht einmal dass er dabei war
schaut mal vorbei ohne den wir dieses
video gewesen aber jetzt bin ich alleine
ja abonniert
[Applaus]